la fiscalía de Kenia ya ha asentado en
el banquillo a varios acusados por la
conocida como masacre del Bosque de
xacahola el principal apoll mckenzi
autoproclamado pastor keniano líder y
fundador de la Iglesia Internacional de
la buena nueva acusado de terrorismo
junto a seis de sus Cómplices por
incitar a sus seguidores a morir de
hambre para encontrarse con Jesús parece
que seguir a Jesucristo es el mayor
crimen de este mundo
solo el juez puede decir eso no yo
habría predicho que el mundo se acabaría
el 15 de abril y ordenado a sus
seguidores que dejaran de comer para
hacer los primeros en ir al cielo junto
a mackenzi otro polémico sacerdote
Ezequiel odero también está siendo
investigado en relación al caso por
crímenes como asesinato radicalización
crímenes de lesa humanidad y fraude las
más de 100 víctimas encontradas en una
fosa común en su mayoría menores
presentan signos nos de inanición pero
también de asfixian algunos casos
mi tía es seguidora de mackenzi la
recogieron aquí y la llevaron al Bosque
Ella volvió recogió a sus hijos y se fue
con ellos al bosque
la masacre ya se ha convertido en una de
las peores del país en los últimos años
y las víctimas aún podrían aumentar ya
que según el Ministerio del interior hay
más de 400 desaparecidos tras los hechos
el gobierno ha asegurado que lanzará un
proyecto de ley para regular las
actividades religiosas en